foreign
is everything working
i'm just gonna wait for
to see if some people are gonna
show up before i start talking
hello savvyper283
hi everyone glad to see some of are
coming can you hear me properly
low volume let me try to fix
that
so is this better
sound problems describe these sound
problems
can you hear me better now
it should be it's better now okay good
hi everyone i'm glad to see so many of
you here
i can't oh so 63 viewers currently
that's very nice
um so yeah i guess
most of you have heard the news already
that we reached a hundred thousand
subscribers by
i think that was yesterday right uh
which is which is crazy uh so just like
i wanted to do this
live stream and talk to you directly and
and thank you all for subscribing for
the fact that you keep watching my
videos that you like
the videos that you comment and have
these wonderful discussions
in the comments section that you share
the videos
it really means so much to me i can't
believe that so many people are even
interested in
what i have to say um but it is very
very inspiring and it is
the reason that i that i
want to keep doing these videos it
really is amazing to know that you're
there
and to have this community
in which i can communicate with you and
you can communicate
amongst each other it's really just
wonderful
so thank you all for for for being here
thank you all for for your
congratulations
um
and so i was just gonna maybe i can
answer some of your questions
uh i'm gonna try to keep up with this
chat here
but also of course i would like to thank
my patrons who keep supporting me
i say this in most of my videos
but without my patrons i wouldn't be
able to make these videos in the way
that i am
the monetary support for my patrons is
really what's helping me
buy the books and and you know be able
to do the research and produce the
videos in the way that i am so
i am eternally grateful for everyone who
supports me in any way if it's
through patreon or just by watching my
videos
[Music]
and i would just like to say also that i
am so thankful for
not just the community on this channel
itself but also the fact that there
seems to have
there's this community that's being
created amongst
creators on youtube itself so you've
seen me collaborate with people like
justin sledge
from esoterica i've done collaborations
with
with zevi from seekers of unity uh i'm
doing stuff with
al mohadema with angela pucca from
angela symposium
so just to thank all of those people
also for for creating such a great
community and also being really
inspiring and and
the fact that we help each other so much
with with this content
it really is such a wonderful thing that
we are able to
um well
provide this kind of content for people
educational content and spread
knowledge on topics that that in a lot
of cases
is is so misunderstood in in wider
society
um i'm going to take a look at some of
your questions here
let me see uh sunday wednesday
asks what got you interested in studying
religion uh
i've been interested in religion and
mythology and stuff like that for as
long as i can remember
um i didn't start out by studying
religion actually started out by
studying uh
international relations so i was kind of
i was interested in
in politics and and ngos and things like
this
um and i've talked about this in a
previous q a but but
as i was trying to get my points for for
my degree in that
i took a course on religion and
already having an interest in that of
course i i talked about this also in my
interview with seekers of unity that as
i was studying international relations i
would often find myself between classes
in the library
reading about different religions and so
i took a class on religion and
immediately just realized that
this is i'm this is for me basically i
was
good at it without bragging like it just
came naturally to me
and it was just so interesting and
important
that i since then i haven't been able to
to let it go basically
what's your name my name is philip
with an f so philip
holm is my last name i'm from sweden
uh let's see
do you think psychedelics have had an
influence in islam
i mean there is certain
evidence that certain substances were
used historically
in sufism for example we have
it also depends on what you didn't sort
of didn't
define as a psychedelic but we have
examples of
um cannabis being smoked of opium and
things like this mostly that wouldn't be
considered a psychedelic necessarily but
those have been commonly
used in order to help in the spiritual
practice alongside
things like coffee but i think most
people wouldn't consider that a
psychedelic either
bring me to the bring me the jews oh uh
will
asks will we see some video on orthodox
christianity or pagan religions
uh orthodox christianity uh definitely
uh i want to get into um
more christianity i think or the
orthodox tradition is the one that is
probably the least talked about and
there's some really interesting
connections to some of the other topics
i've discussed when it comes to
mysticism
there's the hesicasm tradition for
example in eastern
orthodoxy with people like gregory
palamas
which i am planning to do videos on
eventually
because that stuff's just so fascinating
but i always need to do proper research
before i get into stuff
that i that i'm not necessarily as
experienced with as i am with
certain other subjects
do you follow a particular religion
this is one of the the most common
questions i get of course i've answered
this question in
uh in a previous q a also the the most
basic answer is no i i really i don't
i am born into a christian country
culturally so i'm sort of born and
raised in a
culture that is infused with with
christianity in various ways and so i
recognize that that is part of
my dna in a sense but i don't
necessarily
identify as a christian in the sense of
adhering to the theological tenets of
mainstream christianity so
i i at the moment i don't i don't follow
any particular religion i would say
ashkar ali you take care as well i'm
glad to
see you here and i hope you i will see
you in the future in future comments as
well
omama ataturk asks do you think atheism
is a
religion i don't know that's such a
difficult
i mean depends on how we define terms
generally i would say no
atheism is more of a you know the lack
of a belief in a god
i think humans though have a tendency to
find themselves in social situations
where they have certain common beliefs
together and they share those beliefs
with each other and eventually that
looks a lot like what a religion
looks like but in basic terms atheism i
would not necessarily consider that a
religion in that sense i guess but
that's uh
we could have that discussion for a long
time
um so yes uh adam elliott um
i don't know how many you've seen the
the last post i did earlier today
so i've actually have two videos coming
this week
one is coming on thursday and will be a
video on spinoza
and spinoza's god the title is basically
what is spinoza's god
and that is a collaboration that i'm
doing with uh
zavi from seekers of unity
he already did a video on spinoza last
week with with justin from
esoterica but this week uh
i'm doing one as well um and i'm going
to be talking about spinoza
generally but in particular about his
ideas about god
and questions of whether he can be
considered an atheist or a
pantheist or a god intoxicated man as
some people have called them there is a
lot of disagreements about spinoza in
history
about who he was but he really said and
i will be tackling that to some degree
um the second video that's coming out
this week i don't think it's a secret
um
i think i think i can talk about it it's
a collaboration with
angela puka dr angela puka from the
channel
angela symposium and
i in my video at least i will be talking
about sufism
surprise but in particular we're talking
about sufism's relationship to islam
so questions like
what is like is sufism a part of islam
the most general question in what way is
it a part of islam
and what does that relationship look
like both historically and
today that's going to be the video that
comes out
on sunday god willing so two videos this
week i hope you guys are excited about
that
i saw a question
super duper boy 2 will you be making any
more music with morton hilbum i hope
so i really
admire morton and i'm i consider him a
good friend and he's an amazingly
talented percussionist
and as soon as i need someone to play
percussion that he's the first person i
think of so
if if i decided then definitely i will
be working on him in the future as well
[Music]
let's see do a video on wahhabism i
i will i will do a video on wahhabism
i'm planning videos on
ebentamia on wahhabism on salafism
just diving into various aspects and
various branches
and movements within islam
but i always want to of course represent
different movements
in a fair and respectful way as possible
and that goes for those movements as
well and so i want to do my research
properly which i'm
currently doing of course i've studied
islam for many years but still like
you need to since i focus mainly on
sufism i'm not as much of an expert on
salafism for example so i
need to brush up on my knowledge on that
but those videos are definitely
coming
hasan ahmed asks why do you think mystic
traditions from
all over the world irrespective of time
and place have radically similar views
that's the million dollar question
we talked about this in my conversation
with with seekers of unity
i think there are a number of options
that could be
based on on a common uh
intellectual heritage so one thing would
be neoplatonism and
platonism in general is a hugely
important factor in in
the history of mysticism at least in the
sort of western worlds and middle east
and
in europe and in a lot of cases i think
we can trace those similarities to a
movement like neoplatonism or
hermeticism and similar
roots in that sense but if we take that
same
question and extend it to places like
china
like the taoist authors also have very
similar ideas
so i don't i don't know maybe there is
like the second option would be that
there is some kind of
universal human experience that all of
these people are tapping into
and are explaining through different
means and different languages
and that's a very um attractive idea
i don't know if i'm ready to endorse it
completely but that is definitely one
option
nicola frau asks will you make will you
make videos on different buddhist
currents
i i really want to my knowledge on
buddhism is
limited compared to other religions
but i really want to dive into buddhism
particularly i want to talk about some
aspects of mahayana buddhism like the
tiantai
school and and some of those less
known uh movements within buddhism
that's a general kind of uh
tendency on this channel that i want to
highlight lesser-known
more obscure figures or or
schools of thought so i want to do that
i also
in general for the future of this
channel it's a good
time to talk about that now i guess is
that i want to
expand what we're doing here on this
channel i want to
you know eventually when this pandemic
dies down
god willing i want to be able to travel
and and do
more ambitious kind of documentary style
videos without losing the
the
the genetic code of what i'm doing right
now but still like with more
um original b-roll and and
documentary-style footage
from the places that i'm actually
talking about that's one of the things
i'm really looking forward to doing
um but also i'm i'm and this is
something that you'll have to
have a say on as as well but i want to
bring in
scholars to do other rights episodes
or even host episodes on on the channel
on topics that they are more
qualified to speak on than i am because
even though i have studied religion
generally
i have a certain amount of knowledge
about
religion i have specialized in certain
areas i've specialized in islam and in
sufism
i don't know as much about buddhism for
example at all
i don't know anything about indigenous
african religions and so for me to
make videos on that would require a
whole lot of research
and and i would love to collaborate on
projects like that
with people who who are a lot more
experienced
so in various ways i really want to
expand
the scope of this channel in the future
joy paisano is a you're a nakshpandi
muslim that's great i hope you
found my video on the nakshpandiya
i hope you found that that was a fair
representation of your
tradition
uh are you a spiritually realized man
no definitely not
i try my best to live my life according
to the
the values and ideals that i
hold dear but i would not call myself
spiritually realized in in any way
have you ever had a surreal spiritual
experience
i mean kind of but but the nature of all
such experiences are always that you
can't really talk about them in
plain language so i don't know what what
the purpose i could say that there was
one instance when i was in venice i saw
a bird
a duck landing in the water and and i
sort of entered a weird trance-like
state but i can't talk about what that
was like
because i uh it sounds silly when you
just
say it like that but there are there are
certain experiences like that but
but words can't never do them justice
really
would you call yourself a cultural
christian i usually do i guess
but that's also kind of a it's a weird
term because at the end of the day if
you're a culture christian
or you're really a christian a lot of
different
questions come up when you start saying
things but sometimes i do call myself a
cultural christian
let me see if i can
find what's your opinion idea of
orientalism
well i think edward said's book
orientalism is one of the most important
pieces of literature from the 20th
century and i think
every academic today that's like
required reading for everyone
especially if you're the kind of scholar
who talks about the middle east or
well in particular the middle east
so i think that's a very important book
but also very important
movement generally in academia to to try
to
represent the middle east in a more fair
way
and a more less problematic way than
than what
was the case previously
let's see
are you interested in reviewing books on
religious satire for example
small gods by terry pratchett i haven't
heard about that book but that sounds
interesting
i'm basically open to anything i think
i'm the kind of person who's interested
in most things in this world
and so i'm definitely open to it but
that's sort of a new
subject to me um naxra asks do you think
islam is oppressive um
no i mean religions
i would never make generalizing
statements about any religions like that
i think people are oppressive sometimes
some people are not
some muslims can be oppressive some are
not
like it really is people who make up a
religion and people are different
so that's my
position on that what are your thoughts
on dan gibson's work so dan gibson is
the one
he's the guy who talks about uh
mecca being in in petra right that's
that's the
i don't know like i i i think
i think all
how do i put this i think all theories
and ideas are welcome
i think it's healthy to ask questions
and to
try to you know ask difficult questions
and and even
look at very established historical
narratives from from critical
perspectives
that one in particular i'm not so
convinced about
because i think that many of the
these are revisionist school of islamic
studies although i admire a lot of those
scholars
they also tend to take it in my opinion
to the extreme
and also i don't get
i don't see why one should be so
skeptical of the
narratives from within the islamic
tradition like that seems kind of
um not bigoted necessarily but that's
like why
why wouldn't the early muslims know what
they're talking about like
why would they just make
stuff up in that way i think
that comes from a kind of orientalist
speaking orientalism that comes from a
kind of skeptical orientalist
position in a way of not being able to
trust the
sources from within the religion and
just coming up with entirely new
theories without consulting that
tradition
i think the better option is to to be
somewhere in between to ask difficult
questions
but not to discard the traditional
narrative completely
because of that
we'll talk about ahmadi muslims yes
i will i might
so there's there is a there is a group
of media here in sweden i might
try to contact them and do a more
documentary style video on that i don't
know but but that's definitely on my on
my to-do list
what's your favorite piece of sufi
poetry
that's a good question i don't know
because there's so much
the problem with that is that so much of
that
is inaccessible to me
in the original language
and poetry by nature
kind of is so bound up with the language
in which it is written
i don't know persian so i can't read
rumi in persian and i can't read atar in
persian or
saadi or hafez even i do know a little
arabic
and so i i do have diwans by
tillam sani a fifa then tell him sani or
ibn arabi
you know shush study i don't have i
don't actually have
his poetry necessarily but but so the
arabic poetry is more accessible to me
even though my arabic is very limited
but if i have a lexicon with me i can
sort of get through that stuff
and so i've been really into the the
arabic poets in particular i really love
study um and and it will not be
obviously
uh since i've been talking so much about
him i really appreciate
um abner fared is a classic
um but also in translation like
i think in iraqis
is one of the most beautiful pieces of
that's both
prose and poetry uh as well as shabby
studies
gulshani raj and again i've only read
those in translation but
those are just some amazing amazing
pieces of
poetry even in translation
uh you seem to be interested in islam
have you looked into sharia law in the
same way you have
for all the sects in islam what are your
thoughts on it
i won't call sharia law a sect in islam
necessarily that's that's
sort of an aspect of islam i don't have
a general opinion about
sharia that's that's just uh
it's a central part of the islamic
religion and it's it's vast and varied
and there are different
schools of fit in sharia
um i don't know i don't i don't have an
opinion i think
one can certainly admire the development
of the
uh jurisprudence in the islamic world
because it's a very rigorous uh
tradition of law
uh and for its time was
was pretty progressive also in certain
respects but but
i don't know it's it's uh i don't have
any general opinion about that stuff
really
it's interesting i did a video on sharia
on the origins of sharia
i took it down it's privated because
not because i said stuff i didn't agree
with but i
just felt like i could do that video
much better
and it was very much focused on
sunni law in particular
and i would like in if i was to tackle
uh feck
i would want to do that in a more
comprehensive way in the future
will you do a video on new religious
movements code azim yes
i really i look forward to doing that
stuff too
and that's the kind of stuff you can do
more
documentary style videos on once the
pandemic settles
um but yeah i sometimes i feel like this
channel is too focused on old obscure
philosophers from the middle ages
and so i try to to make topics or make
videos on topics that are more
uh relevant to to well not that those
aren't relevant but but about things
that are
happening right now and and there is so
much interesting stuff with new
religious movements
that i would love to to tackle in the
future i did shoot a video
a few years ago from like a convention
here in stockholm
so new age convention i took a bunch of
footage and i never really did anything
with it
i might incorporate that into a video in
the future
uh but there's a lot of that going on
here at least
yeah that's a whole ocean of stuff
karai juice yeah sure i
don't i know so little about it that i
that's
that's gonna have to be in the future
but but definitely like
all of your suggestions are are
great and i would love to do most of
that stuff
i just need to make the time to do the
research
i have a long long list of
videos that i want to do including many
of your suggestions
um but i can only do one video at a time
but i appreciate all your suggestions
and i do write them down most of the
time so
keep them coming
yes
yeah again yes i'll probably get there
in the future
some of these figures like i've like um
i would love to do and i've wanted to do
a video on mulasadra for example for so
long
um and that's one of the most requested
video topics on this entire channel
um so many people have like continuously
been like where is the video on
malasadra
and and i i i want to do that
but that's one of those videos where i
feel like if i'm going to talk about
mulasadra
i need to talk about eben arabi and ibn
sina and surah varadi
first and i've only talked about ibn
alabi and
even cena and i might even want to redo
the ibn cena episode
but before i do malasada i will have to
do surah bharadi for example
because malasada is so based on
interpreting those
earlier thinkers that we you need to lay
the groundwork before you can
get there so in some cases when it comes
to these topics
it's just a matter of me not having sort
of
having to do one video at a time but
sometimes it's also a matter of
wanting to do things in in a bit of a
chronological way
for it to make as much sense as possible
what do you think about the scientific
inaccuracies in religions
that's i don't know that's a difficult
topic
i am generally a supporter of science
and
if something is
proven according to science then i tend
to to to
follow that as part of my world view
but religions are pretty good at
adapting to to new
scientific findings and and uh
developments
uh you know
a common question is like what would
happen to religions if aliens came to
to earth and that depends on their
religion of course
but and i think
you've all heard of reza aslan right you
can
have whatever opinion you want about him
but sometimes he says pretty
interesting stuff and so he was asked
that question and he said
uh you know that if aliens came to earth
then religions will
take that information and and
incorporate it and move on like it would
not destroy religion religions have the
amazing ability
to to adapt and change with the times
and
that's not going to stop any time soon
okay let's see
again i already answered that question i
will be making videos on
on that stuff what do i think of
zarathustra
i like sarah thurston i think he's an
incredibly important figure in the
history of religion and the history of
philosophy
[Music]
i made a video on zoroastrianism um
and some of those ideas that seems to
have been introduced by sarah thurston
the dualistic
theology um the idea of a excuse me
the idea of a day of judgment and heaven
and hell and so on
seems to originate from historical
perspective right
seems to originate from uh
zoroastrianism and from
the teachings of to some degree
sarathustra
and so zerationism is such an important
religion for the history of religion
generally
because it is the source from which so
much of the major
components of some of the major
religions today
come from and not only in terms of
religion but also in philosophy
the persians were a huge inspiration for
certain
uh greek thinkers and and and so on so
sarah thursday is
a significant albeit not
too well-known figure in in history
a lot of questions i'm just trying to
thoughts on life after death i'm not
opening that can of worms
i'm not going to act like i have any
answers to that question
any tips you would give small youtubers
just keep
going man just like keep making videos
one suggestion is like to try to be as
consistent as possible
i i started this channel
over three years ago now that's 2018
and just one year ago like
around the the turn of the like new
year's i had like 200 subscribers
so for the first two years i had
accumulated 200 subscribers
and then now a year later we're at 100
000. and i think one of the things that
helped in that
um increase in numbers
was the fact that i started to be more
consistent with my postings i would try
to do
at least once every two weeks or maybe
sometimes even every week try to do a
video
and i think that helped with the
algorithms and whatnot
so i i would say just keep going and and
hopefully eventually
things start to look up
comparison video between ibn arabi and
shankara
it's inevitable that i will someday make
that kind of video i guess
because um i do kind of make i don't
really make comparisons but i talk about
that in both of those videos
so i mentioned shankara in lebanon video
and i mentioned
the um
because there are so many similarities
not only between them but also with
maestro eckhart
and johnson and so on there's a book
oh no i don't remember the author of of
the book
but it's called path to transcendence
and it basically
compares ibn arabi um
maestro eckhart and um and shankara
and their different monistic ideas
because there are so many similarities
will you ever share your music i shared
my music the other day
many people asked about the music about
the background music in my videos most
of the videos use
my own background my own music so i've
composed
certain music specifically
to have as background music in my videos
the the intro music to my uh
the making of the muslim world uh
making the muslim world series is also
my own composition so all of that is
i try to make my own music as much as
possible and all of that is available
most of it is available on spotify under
my name philippe paul
if any of you want to check it out i
also shared the other day a song by
a project of mine called zeni
which is sort of a band but not really a
band i don't know
what's going on with that but but it's
it's a project that aims more
specifically to
mix different genres and and to explore
different musical cultures from around
the world
um and and have them sort of
meet and and co-mingle
in in a sort of weird soup of
great music so um
but i will like as soon as i release a
new song or something i'll i'll
let you guys know if you're interested
what sect would you be if you were
muslim
i don't know if if i knew that i
probably would be one of those
i uh you you guys can probably tell that
i
admire sufi's i like the ideas of some
sufis
um i don't know i i don't know what to
answer
how to answer that question without you
guys misinterpreting me or
me sounding like i say something strange
well
i'll avoid that please make a video on
vaishnavism yes so i will be i did have
my video on shankara and i'd wait the
vedanta and
a natural follow-up to that is the video
on the
ramanuja and his vishishtadvaita
which is intimately connected to
vaishnavism like that's
according to some at least that's the
mainstream theology
of of vaishnavism i will also be making
videos on shaivism
in particular kashmir shaivism and
abhinava gupta
and and i don't know if i'm pronouncing
that right that's
a female poet who lived in kashmir she
belonged to the kashmir shaivism
tradition just an amazing personality
and so i
all of that is again i want to talk
about everything but those are some
things that i have
planned at least pretty soon
so many comments i'm trying to keep up
here
please make a video on
it disappeared a lot of you want to make
me want to make me want me to forgot how
to speak
a lot of you want me to make videos on
abdul qadr al-jilani
the founder of the kaduri order
and uh that's definitely also something
that i plan to do i did a video on the
nakshpandi order i did one on the
nematodhi order
and and those you guys really seem to
appreciate those videos and so i will
keep um i will keep making videos about
different sufi orders i want to do one
on the shadowly order
on the shishtiya and of course on the
kadaria and in that video
i will be like when we talk about the
kadaria
that's what we'll talk about most of the
time is
the sort of founder of that tradition
maybe we could do like a poll sometime
maybe i could do a poll on my patreon
page
about like which sufi order should i
tackle next because uh
that is after all my my primary field of
expertise and
something that i love talking about so
more survivorism
is coming whether you like it or not
do you have plans for doing a video on
ebentamia yes
i stated that earlier as well i i will
be
i am currently researching the video on
eben tamiya
[Music]
have you read the quran uh yeah not in
the original language i've only read
some of the
shortest uh suras in in arabic uh but
other than that i've read it in
translation
i don't think i've read the entire thing
because i haven't read it like from
front to back but more sporadically but
i've read
i would say most of the quran
like if you study islam to the degree
that someone like me
does like how could you not read the
quran
it's
that's like the is it the core of the
whole thing
do a video on akbar and his religion
again yes the i haven't tackled the
mughal period at all actually
and that is like especially in terms of
sufism there is so much interesting
stuff there
akbar um and aurangzeb
um in particular and his his um
for those who don't know darashoka was a
mughal prince
he was the great grandson of akbar
and he was a sufi
practicing sufi he wrote
some really great treatises including a
book called the compass of truth which
sort of explicates the
doctrine of the unity of being but he
also wrote a book called the
need majme or mingling of the two oceans
referring to islam
and hinduism and so what he would do is
he would study the upanishads
and talk to various hindu sages
and he would hold the opinion that what
the hindus
say is basically the same at least in
its
core core aspects it's the same as what
we're talking about in in islam
especially as understood through
sufism and so he would try to
um in this book in particular he would
he would try to sort of
have these two traditions meet and then
he was
executed by his brother aurangazeb
unfortunately what made you study islam
that's a very good question
i've always been interested in the sort
of the middle east
in general i've always had a kind of
a love for the aesthetics
and just the culture there in general
has always intrigued me
i guess that's one aspect of it but i
think
primary reason why i started getting
like specializing in islam in particular
was because there was so much
misinformation about islam because i had
grown up
in a area in sweden
in stockholm that was very multicultural
and basically the majority of my friends
i would say
at least a good amount of my friends
growing up were muslims
and i would hang out with them and i
would spend time in their homes with
their families and and so on
and then once i got out into the wider
world and realized there was so much
prejudice against muslims and racism and
bigotry and
really like misinformation because the
version of islam that was
presented to me or the people were
talking about did not correspond to my
experiences
growing up at all and so that
sort of sparked a wish in me to
to sort of try to understand
better that perhaps that religion in
particular and it'd be or
in order to help change that narrative
that is so negative today about islam
and again at least that's one of i think
there are many different reasons and
factors that that led to my
decision to specialize in that in
particular but that's definitely one
aspect
is there any logic behind the beard on
your face probably not no
it's just just kind of there i don't
really do anything with it i just let it
grow
sometimes i trim it sometimes i cut it
and i don't know the logic of beards
that's an interesting
topic
i think i just look so young
i look younger than i want to look if i
don't have the beard so i try to
keep it on
maybe i should like a b like uh beard
beardless face reveal when we reach 500
000 or something
although you can find videos on me
without the beard from a couple years
ago
do you see yourself converting to islam
not anytime soon i don't have any plans
to
nordic mysticism nordic religion in
general
sounds like a natural fit for me
because i'm from sweden and i talk about
religion so i should naturally talk
about nordic religions
if you want a recommendation there's a
great channel
i suppose many of you heard of jackson
crawford on youtube he's just amazing
he is he just he's a he's an american
and he's a channel he's an expert on on
in norse like the language primarily but
also
generally like the culture and religion
of ancient
norse or in the ancient nordic peoples
and his entire video is just him
standing in front of beautiful
mountains in colorado and talking about
thor it's like the most amazing thing
upload into podcasts yes i mean i've
definitely thought about that
about doing a podcast
i don't know if i have the time to do a
podcast these videos
are are enough as it is
but i think this stuff could also work
very well in podcast form
so that's something i've been i've been
thinking about definitely
would you guys want a podcast do you
like do you guys really want me to do a
podcast because i'll definitely consider
it
when is your next video on thursday i'm
i'm releasing a video on
spinoza spinoza's god
which should be interesting and then i
do a video on
sufism on sunday god willing
and and then i'm writing a video
about the
taibi or taiyubi ismailis like the
daodiboras and the suleimani
taibis
i'm also i've also started to work on a
video about
pre-islamic arabia and the religions
of pre-islamic arabia
which i don't know when that's going to
come up but i've started working on that
[Music]
and then i'm as i said i reach i'm
researching various stuff like the video
on intaymia for example
there's a lot of stuff coming
jason harris first congrats thank you
second do you think religion is entirely
a human construct or have actually
touched on spiritual worlds from time to
time through our existence
well i am of the opinion that that
religions
are social constructs that people create
religions
that does not necessarily mean that
there can't be truths
within or that that are expressed in
those religions
and that people have experienced some
spark of that truth that has inspired
certain
things within religions i am definitely
open to that idea
but religions in terms of um
you know certain practices or beliefs
and
institutionalized
communities or or practices
i am of the opinion that those are for
the most part
social constructs are you going to write
a book
uh i i would like to write a book i
don't know why i'll write a book on
yet
[Music]
but definitely in the future
please do more review movie reviews like
you did on snyder's batman vs superman
oh so you're the guy who watched that
video um
i appreciate that um that was kind of
fun to make
that was i did a video that was like a
year ago where i
had looked at some uh what i consider to
be
christian imagery and symbolism in the
movie bad memories to superman
um
and it's not one of my more successful
videos but but
it's a fun little thing i've definitely
thought about doing more
pop culture videos i did one on
assassin's creed the other week
uh and i would love to do more stuff
like that like if there's a video game
or movie that comes out that deals with
a certain religion or aspects of
religion in some way i would
i could for example do a review of that
failed more video games
the way that that film or video game
portrays religion
or a specific religion for example um
i think that could be really interesting
because religion is often so
badly portrayed in pop culture i would
say
so many questions trying to pick a good
one
[Music]
thoughts on sikhism i love i love
sikhism
i think sikhism is such a fascinating
tradition
and i've held off on doing videos on
sikhism
so here's the thing right when i started
this channel
i i wanted as much as possible
i really haven't uh upheld this ideal
but i wanted originally
for people from a certain religious
tradition
to represent themselves and for it not
to be just
some european guy
because you see all these documentaries
about
india and there's a british guy
walking around in india talking about
what indians are like
or indian religion and it's always like
that it's always
the white person who who explains
who who who who portrays the the
the other people and i wanted for people
from certain distribution to be able to
represent themselves
that didn't really happen because i've
become sort of the face of this channel
in a way and i talk about most of these
subjects
um but i was in in contact with a group
of sikhs in stockholm
prior to the pandemic and i wanted to do
a documentary on sikhism rather than
just a regular video like for other like
the other videos i've done
but then the pandemic happened that
hasn't happened but but
but i think sikhism
i will have to do what they don't seek
is in one way or the other eventually
who would win in a fight muhammad or
buddha or let's talk with alma can i
touch that one
so do you believe humans evolved from
apes
well generally i think
that the theory of evolution
is a good theory
for the origins of the
human race i'll put it like that
it is a theory that i generally accept
as being probably true
how did islam or the starting of islam
affect you as a person
i think i don't know
i think it made me a more open
understanding person i think
that's the general idea of this channel
that information and knowledge
leads to better understanding and better
opportunities for conversation and
tolerance for example
and i think studying different religions
has helped me become
a more open and better person including
islam
islam in particular
that's a difficult question if that in
particular has affected me in some way
i'm sure it has
[Music]
i'll have to think about that one but
generally i think it's it's made me
a more open and accepting person
dmt will show you what
what's it gonna show me
i haven't i haven't smoked a dmt
and i don't have any plans to at the
moment
have you ever read about aztec
philosophy not really like that is a
field that i am very much in the dark
about
but i've wanted to for so long
i know nothing about it like i know i
know some i know
some like quetzalcoatl the serpent god
and i know about sacrifices like i
really
don't know much about that stuff at all
so
i look forward to to
to reading about that
please do a video on monkey god
so is that like a reference to hanuman
in hinduism for example
i had a discussion with someone i don't
remember it was but but the idea was
like what if i made videos on particular
gods
like in different mythologies but i
don't think that's necessarily within
the scope of what i do on this channel
i think that's more there are great
mythology channels on youtube that make
those kinds of videos
i'll definitely bring up those kinds of
gods
like hanuman as an important god in
hinduism like he will come up
naturally
how do you study do you have any teacher
or guide
i mean yeah of course i had teachers i
studied at university for
the better part of a decade this sort of
stuff and
i had many great teachers and professors
don't have like a like a guru or a
sheikh in the spiritual sense
if that's what you're asking um but
teachers definitely
we all need teachers we can't do this
stuff on our own
even if even to fail claims that we can
in
higher yaksan i don't necessarily buy
that
so my sound is only on the left side
yeah that looks like that's true that's
strange
i'll have to so the first time i'm doing
a kind of a
um a live stream like this so uh
it's kind of a
i i learn as i go i'm not as experienced
with this so
if if i don't i don't think i can fix
that sound problem at the moment but
i'll try to fix that for for next
time this is kind of fun actually i
would love to do more live streams in
the future
so how long have i been streaming now
where can i see that oh almost an hour
okay so we're not going to be going for
that much longer i actually have a video
to to record
so i'm sure you can forgive me for not
staying
too long would you ever do a video on
neoplatonism yes
i had this conversation with my wife
today i said i really want to do a video
on platinus
and neoplatonism but i have to justify
to myself why does that belong on a
channel about religion
because he's mostly considered a
philosopher but
i think there's a natural connection
there because neoplatonism is so
important for the theology and
philosophy of some of the major
religions like christianity and islam
at least certain aspects of that
or those religions have been so
influenced by neoplatonism as well as
judaism
um i think that kind of clears me right
that because i really want to do that
video
the armenia apostolic church yeah i mean
generally
eastern like orthodox christianity
i want to do stuff about
um hezekiasm geggrypalamas
all that good stuff
so i think i'm going to start to
end this stream if you guys want to
see me do more streams like this you
just let me know because
now i know kind of how to do it so we
can do more in the future
um
i'm so happy that i'm so happy that many
of you showed up today
i wasn't expecting so many to show up
and the fact that you keep watching this
channel
um as i said i started this channel
almost three years ago
um with the aim of
trying to spread more
scholarly and academic content about
religion
on on on the internet because the stuff
that was there
was so terrible like this
most of the content about these subjects
are not good
at all since i've started this channel
there has been some really
great new channels that have appeared
but nonetheless i
really wanted to do my part to change
that environment
and to
well spread knowledge about a subject
that is so often misunderstood
uh in order to to to help people
get a better grasp of the complexity of
the subject but also to understand
what other people think and how they
practice and what they do
and through that be able to start
conversations
and also as uh zevi and the seekers of
unity pointed out so well
it has also been one of my main
agendas to
give certain religious traditions the
respect that they deserve
because we live in a post-enlightenment
world
where religions are often looked down
upon um
everything pre-enlightenment is seen as
something irrational and
like like the dark ages and we were
ignorant and now we're enlightened then
we know what we're talking about right
but that's that's just not the case
it's it's so well exemplified by the
fact that when we talk about philosophy
for example
where things have gotten better in the
last few decades but it's still kind of
paradigm where we talk about the greeks
talk about socrates and plato and
aristotle and
maybe the stoics and maybe platinus
and then we kind of skip a thousand
years and we start again at the
renaissance or even the enlightenment
as a whole thousand years of development
there that is that is so important and
the fact that thinkers
within religious traditions have
contributed significantly to the
intellectual history
um and can offer us things even today
and i think that's also one of the
things that i want to do with many of
these videos right when i talk about
many of these thinkers
is to highlight that people
in the middle ages weren't stupid like
they didn't believe these things because
they were ignorant they're actually very
intelligent people
with developed and and and very
deep philosophical or theological views
and that i wanted in that sense to
to give it the respect that it deserves
i
i hope that and it seems
that that this channel has provided a
kind of community for
conversation about religion that is on a
much better level we can understand each
other much better
um as i said in the beginning i'm so
also also thankful for the community
that's been started
um in terms of the different creators
here um
i saw one of you in the chat i think but
people like dr justin sledge and and
zevi
from seekers of unity and angela puka
and even andrew henry from religion for
breakfast who
haven't worked with him yet of course
but be like he's been
like a pioneer here on youtube and he's
been a great inspiration
and he has helped me out on several
occasions like all these people it's
such a great
community of people that are making
fantastic content right now and i'm so
happy for that
and yeah i think i'm going to try to end
it here
so
i'll read some of your comments um
afterwards
i'm sorry i didn't get to all of your
questions there were so many questions
um and i'll do more live streams like in
this future but i wanted to take this
this this opportunity now that we've
reached 100 000 subscribers
to primarily to just thank you all for
for being here and for
the fact that you keep showing up um
and uh yeah look forward to two videos
this week and then more stuff in the
future
uh so yeah i'll talk to you soon i'll
see you on thursday not
live but in the future video and i hope
you guys
have a great day and that you
take care of yourselves and of each
other and i'll see you soon
okay bye bye